thank you very much everyone thank you
thank you
beautiful day in the Rose Garden
appreciate everybody being here today
I'd like to provide an update to the
American people on several decisive
divisive new actions were taking in our
very vigilant effort to combat and
ultimately defeat the corona fire virus
we've been working very hard on this
we've made tremendous progress when you
compare what we've done to other areas
of the world it's a it's pretty
incredible a lot of that had to do with
the early designation and the closing of
the borders then as you know Europe was
just designated as the hot spot right
now and we close that border while ago
so that was lucky or through Talent or
through luck call or whatever you want
but through a very collective action and
shared sacrifice national determination
we will overcome the threat of the virus
I also announced Wednesday night
following the advice of our medical
professionals who are doing a tremendous
job and we appreciate it very much that
we're suspending the entry of foreign
nationals who have been to Europe in the
last 14 days from entering the United
States citizens permanent residents and
our families any of the families
returning from Europe will be subject to
extra screening as well as self
isolation for a period of 14 days as the
World Health Organization confirmed
today many of the things that what we
said were 100% correct including our
designation before them of Europe like
our earlier very aggressive actions with
China this measure will save countless
lives I appreciate a number of the folks
behind me a lot number the people behind
me said that that saved a lot of lives
that early designation but it is only
the beginning of what we're really doing
and now we're and if
in Phase we had some very old and
obsolete rules that we had to live with
it worked under certain circumstances
but not under masked circumstances they
were there for a long time they were in
place for a long time and we're breaking
them down now
and they're very usable for certain
instances but not for this to unleash
the full power of the federal government
that this effort today I am officially
declaring a national emergency two very
big words the action I am taking will
open up access to up to fifty billion
dollars of very importantly very
important and a large amount of money
for states and territories and
localities and our shared fight against
this disease in furtherance of the order
emerging every state to set up emergency
operation centers effective immediately
you're going to be hearing from some of
the largest companies and greatest
retailers and medical companies in the
world they're standing right behind me
on the side of me I'm also asking every
hospital in this country to activate its
emergency preparedness plan so that they
can meet the needs of Americans
everywhere the hospitals are very
engaged New York and various other
places are also various engaged I just
spoke with Governor Cuomo we had a very
good conversation and we're working very
strongly with many states including New
York the emergency orders I'm issuing
today will also confer broad new
authority to the Secretary of Health and
Human Services the Secretary of HHS will
be able to immediately waive provisions
of applicable laws and regulations to
give doctors hospital all hospitals and
health care providers maximum
flexibility to respond to the virus and
care for patients this includes the
following critical authorities the
ability to waive laws to enable
telehealth
a fairly new
and incredible thing that's happened in
the in the not-so-distant past I tell
you what they've done with telehealth is
incredible it gives a remote doctor's
visits and hospital check-ins the power
to waive certain federal license
requirements so that doctors from other
states can provide services and states
with the greatest need
number two the ability to waive
requirements that critical access
hospitals limit the number of beds to
twenty five and a length of stay to 96
hours the ability to waive the
requirements of a three day hospital
stay prior to admission to a nursing
home big thing the authority to waive
the rules to hinder hospital's ability
to bring additional physicians on board
or obtain needed office space they can
do as they want they can do what they
have to do they know what they have to
do now they don't have any problem
getting it done the authority to waive
rules that severely restrict where
hospitals can care for patients within
the hospital itself ensuring that the
emergency capacity can be quickly
established will remove or eliminate
every obstacle necessary to deliver our
people the care that they need and that
they're entitled to no resource will be
spared nothing whatever ten days ago I
brought together CEOs of commercial labs
at the White House and directed them to
immediately begin working on a solution
to dramatically increase the
availability of tests other countries
have called us and worked with us and
they're doing similar things or will be
doing similar things as a result of that
action today we are announcing a new
partnership with private sector to
vastly increase and accelerate our
capacity to test for the coronavirus we
want to make sure that those who need a
test can get a test very safely quickly
and conveniently but we don't want
people to take a test if if we feel
they shouldn't be doing it and we don't
want everyone running out and taking
only if you have certain symptoms using
federal emergency authorities the FDA
approved a new test for the virus we did
this within hours after receiving the
application from Roche a process that
would normally take weeks we therefore
expect up to a half a million additional
tests will be available early next week
we'll be announcing locations probably
on Sunday night
I want to thank Roche great company for
their incredible work I'd also like to
thank thermo Fisher the FDA's goal is to
hopefully authorize the air application
within 24 hours it'll go very quickly
it's going very quickly which will bring
additionally 1.4 million tests onboard
next week and five million within a
month I doubt we'll need anywhere near
that at the same time we've been in
discussions with pharmacies and
retailers to make drive-through tests
available in the critical locations
identified by public health
professionals the goal is for
individuals to be able to drive up and
be swamped without having to leave your
car I want to thank Google Google is
helping to develop a website it's going
to be very quickly done unlike websites
of the past to determine whether a test
is warranted and to facilitate testing
at a nearby convenient location we have
many many locations behind us by the way
we cover the this country in large parts
of the world by the way we're not going
to be talking about the world right now
but we cover very very strongly our
country stores in virtually every
location Google has 1,700 engineers
working on this right now they've made
tremendous progress our overriding goal
is to stop the spread of the virus and
to help all Americans who have been
impacted by this again we don't want
everybody taking this test it's totally
unnecessary and this will pass
this will pass through and we're going
to be even stronger for it we've learned
a lot tremendous amount has been learned
I want to thank deborah birx and i want
to ask her maybe to come up and say a
few words as to what's happening dr.
Burks is a highly respected person I've
gotten to know very well over the last
six days and what we've done is rebuilt
something that was very old very old
fashioned somewhat obsolete certainly
obsolete when it comes to the kind of
numbers that we're talking about dr.
Burks please thank you Thank You mr.
president Tom it's a pleasure to be here
with all of you I think you know at the
beginning of this epidemic HHS through
CDC proactively developed an assay built
on the existing flu surveillance system
that surveillance system was then
converted to diagnostic system but last
Tuesday seeing the spread of the virus
around the globe the president realized
that our current approach to testing was
inadequate to need to meet the needs of
the American public he asked for an
entire overhaul of the testing approach
he immediately called the private sector
laboratories to the White House as noted
and charge them with developing a high
throughput quality platform that can
meet the needs of the American public we
are grateful to LabCorp and quest for
taking up the charge immediately after
the meeting and within seventy now at 72
hours bringing additional testing access
particularly to the outbreak areas of
Washington State and California and now
across the country we are also very
grateful to the universities in large
hospital systems that took up the charge
developed their own quality tests made
available by new dep new FDA guidance
this has resulted in expanded testing
across New York California Washington
Colorado and you see sometimes those
drive-thru options that have been made
available through these high-throughput
options following the meeting last week
major commercial laboratory equipment
and diagnostic companies took immediate
action
to adopt and develop new testing systems
last night the initial company Roche
received sta FDA approval moving from
request to development to approval in
record time this innovative approach
centered fully on unleashing the power
of the private sector focusing on
providing convenient testing to hundreds
of thousands of Americans within short
turnaround times in less than two weeks
together we have a developed a solution
that we believe will meet the future
needs testing needs of Americans I
understand how difficult this has been I
was part of the hiv/aids response in the
80s we knew from dying from first
finding cases in 1981 it took us to
almost 1985 to have a test it took us
another 11 years to have effective
therapy it is because of the lessons
learned from that that we were able to
mobilize and bring those individuals
that were key to the HIV response to
this response I understand that a lot of
this behind-the-scenes action over the
last couple of weeks was invisible to
the press and the American people but
this intense effort has not only
resulted in innovative solutions but an
automated high throughput system
bringing the availability of these
quality Korona viral testing to the
American people at unprecedented speed
finally I want you to know in South
Korea they did have large number of
tests available over the last several
weeks their positivity rate is between
three and four percent with LabCorp and
quest expanded testing their positivity
rate is between one and two percent so
we want to also announce this new
approach to testing which will start in
the screening website up here
facilitated by Google where clients and
patients and people that interest can go
fill out a screening questionnaire move
down for symptoms or risk factors yes
they would move down this and be told
where the drive through options would be
for them to receive this
the labs will then move to the
high-throughput automated machines to be
able to provide results in 24 to 36
hours that is the intent of this
approach we have seen at work just in
our own United States and we want to
bring this across the continent thank
you very much I'd like to make we have
Tony do you want to come up you become a
yeah
yeah I think everybody out here knows
you pretty well but Tony has been doing
a tremendous job working long long hours
and you've seen a lot happen but this
has been it's been a great experience
and working with you has been terrific
Tony please thank you very much
mr. president this is an example of
another example of what I've been
referring to in my discussions with many
of you in the audience as a proactive
leaning forward aggressive trying to
stay ahead of the curve and what you've
seen now with this order is that we're
going to be able to remove the
constraints so that people at the state
the local level the individual physician
all the way up through the federal
government will have as many constraints
as possible removed for them to do
everything they possibly can so that we
can implement the things that we've been
talking about the containment the
mitigation so that as I've said many
times that curve that I refer to that
goes up we don't want to have that curve
we want to suppress it down to that
small mound and I think what we've done
today is something that is going to be a
very important element in having us be
successful in doing that we still have a
long way to go there will be many more
cases but we'll take care of that and
ultimately as the president said this
will end but what's going on here today
is going to help but to end sooner than
it would have thank you thank you very
much
if I could some of these folks we know
they're celebrities in their own right
they're the biggest business people the
greatest retailers anywhere in the world
and one of them is Doug McMillon from
Walmart and I'd like to have Doug if you
would say a few words wherever you may
be please when we got the call yesterday
from the White House we were eager to do
our part to help serve the country and
given what we're facing that's certainly
important to do we should all be doing
that so we've been asked to make
portions of our parking lot available in
select locations in the beginning and
scaling overtime as supply increases so
that people can experience the drive
their experience that the president
described
we'll stay involved and do everything we
can from a supply chain point of view to
be of assistance thank you sir thank you
very much very much I'll just stay right
over here and Richard if you could come
up please Richard please Walgreens thank
you thank you mr. president and similar
to to Doug and Walmart we're happy to
stand in here and help in communities
all across America because a lot of
times when we have natural disasters our
stores are a beacon in the community and
this situation is no different so we
look forward to partnering with the CDC
the administration HHS and the task
force and specifically to the vice
president's doing such a fantastic job
we're ready to engage in help thank you
thank you very much great job thank you
very much Brian Cornell Target thank you
Brian
thank you please well mr. president
thank you for inviting us here today
along with our colleagues from Walmart
and Walgreens and our partners at CVS
normally us as competitors but today
we're focused on a common competitor and
that's the feeding the spread of the
coronavirus and we look forward to
working with the administration to do
our fair share to alleviate this growing
threat so thank you for including us
today in the near term we're all
committed to making sure we're keeping
our stores open to serve the American
consumer who's rapidly stocking up on
household essentials key food and
beverage items that they need during
this time making sure we run safe stores
and create an environment that's safe
for our team members with making sure
that they feel supported during this
very critical time
so thank you for including I see very
much great job is Tom here Tom Paula
please Thank You mr. president as CEO of
Becton Dickinson were one of the leading
providers of medical devices as well as
collection products for testing of
coronavirus we were wrapping up our
manufacturing capacity to ensure that
the right collection devices and testing
equipment are ready to to address this
issue
Stephen Rakowski quest Diagnostics
please great job thank you thank you
very much Thank You mr. president so as
mentioned we recalled the leadership of
the vice president last week to come
together as an industry and we took
advantage of that opportunity to work
with the FDA to work with the Center for
Disease Control and we were up and
running with tests in a number of our
facilities as the president mentioned we
now have capabilities from Roche
Diagnostics that will bring into our
facilities this weekend and I know
myself and us my colleague at LabCorp
will be doing the same so the capacity
available to American public to support
this action with consumers will be
considerably increased in the next few
weeks Thank You mr. Presley very much I
appreciate it
Thanks and Matt sauce please have Roche
Matt thank you man
Thank You mr. president so from Roche we
want to thank the FDA for their rapid
approval of our coronavirus tests we
really appreciate the partnership with
the CDC and the FDA to get that to
market as fast as possible because it's
critical for us to make that available
to help patients in need and working
with laboratories to get it up and going
in the near future which will bring
hundreds of thousands of tests available
to patients in need in the United States
so thank you and you can do it you can
do it the great company
David Pierre of signify signify health
please thanks Thank You mr. president
we are the largest house-call provider
and the US and we go to the homes of the
most vulnerable elderly and through our
network
and our logistics engine we stand ready
to help and provide our clinicians to be
where they're needed whether they're in
retail clinics or in the home and we're
here to assist thank you very much thank
you and we'll be changing a lot of the
rules regulations for future should this
happen in the future which we hope it
never does but it will I guess somewhere
out there some bad ones over the years
and I guess that'll continue to an
extent but we hope it never happens but
we're going to be changing a lot of the
old rules and specifications and
regulations Adams Schechter who has
really been of tremendous help
LabCorp please Adam Thank You mr.
president
at LabCorp we're working every second of
every day to increase the number of
tests that we can run we're working with
academic medical centers with our
colleagues at Quest with other hospital
and other laboratories to ensure that we
do everything we can to increase the
testing as we move forward and I can
tell you we understand how important the
testing is and we are committed to doing
everything possible thank you thank you
Thomas Moriarty CVS we all know CVS
thank you thank you thank you Jones
Thank You mr. president
we have been focused since the start of
making sure our patients and the
customers we serve have the information
they need the safety they need as well
we are committed to working with the
administration and local public health
officials to make this work as well and
thank you sir for the honor thank you
very much thank you jeff and bruce
Greenstein LHC Group tremendously
talented people thank you very much mr.
president thank you for the honor being
here and the home health industry has
been treating patients and seniors and
the safety and comfort of their own home
for decades we're very proud to be part
of the equation for testing in their own
home for Americans they can't get to a
test site or live in rural areas far
away from a retail establishment we're
here to help to partner with our
hospitals and physicians as well as the
people we have here today that will be
doing testing around the country thank
you
okay I like that that's good also
announcing the following emergency
executive actions today to help our
students and their families I've waved
interest at all student loans held by
federal government agencies and that
will be until further notice that's a
big thing for a lot of students that are
left in the middle right now many of
those schools have been closed based on
the price of oil I've also instructed
the Secretary of Energy to purchase that
a very good price large quantities of
crude oil for storage in the US
strategic reserve we're going to fill it
right up to the top saving the American
taxpayer billions and billions of
dollars helping our oil industry and
making us even further with that
wonderful goal which we've achieved
which nobody thought was possible of
energy independence it puts us in a
position that's very strong and we're
buying it at the right price and that's
something that would have not even been
possible a week ago the price of oil
went down quite a bit so we're gonna
fill it up there's a good time to fill
it up
I'd like to ask Mike Pence to say a few
words please VP Thank You mr. president
it is this day should be an inspiration
to every American because thanks to your
leadership from early on not only are we
bringing a whole-of-government approach
to confronting the coronavirus we're
bringing in all of America approach mr.
president from early on you took
decisive action you suspended all travel
from China you created travel advisories
South Korea in Italy we screened all
travelers from all airports in both of
those countries and on the unanimous
recommendation of your health experts
you at midnight tonight will effectively
suspend all travel from Europe and
Americans that were returning will be
screened and asked to voluntarily
participate in a 14-day corn
throughout this process mr. president
you've put the health of America first
but you brought the best of America to
address it and it's not just at the
federal level as you said mr. president
we've been working with states across
the country we issued broad guidelines
from CDC for every American
but this week at your direction we
tailored specific recommendations from
CDC for New York Washington state
California Massachusetts in Florida and
we've been in continuous contact as you
said with governor's around the country
mr. president you have forged a seamless
partnership with every state in every
territory in this country to put the
health of our nation first but today I
trusted people around the country that
are looking on at this extraordinary
public and private partnership to
address the issue of testing with
particular inspiration after you tapped
me to lead the White House Corona task
force mr. president you said this is all
hands on deck and you directed us to
immediately reach out to the American
business sector commercial labs to meet
what we knew then would be the need for
testing across the spectrum and today
with this historic public-private
partnership we have laid the foundation
to meet that need for Americans looking
on by this Sunday evening we'll be able
to give specific guidance on uh on when
the website will be available you can go
to the website as the president said
you'll type in your symptoms and be
given Direction whether or not a test is
indicated and then at the same website
you'll be directed to one of these
incredible companies that are gonna give
a little bit of their parking lot so
that people can come by and do a
drive-by test mr. president I want to
join you in thanking Walmart CVS and
Target and Walgreens these are companies
that are synonymous with communities
large and small where people come
together and now they're gonna come
together to meet the needs of the
American public these commercial
laboratories LabCorp and quest and Roche
have just done an incredible job
stepping forward and they're gonna
literally make literally make hundreds
of thousands
of tests available and being processed
with results to patients in the very
near future but it's all a result of you
tasking us with bringing together not
just government resources which all
state labs can now test across the
country CDC is testing but you said mr.
president that we wanted to bring all
the resources the country together and
that's what this partnership really
means you know truth is that we have
coronavirus cases now in 46 American
states and while the risk of serious
illness of the corona virus remains low
we want to encourage every American to
practice common-sense practice good
hygiene go to the CDC's website to see
what the guidance is for your community
or for the American people broadly and
as the president has said it's
especially important now that we look
after senior citizens with chronic
underlying health conditions
last week the president directed the
Center for Medicaid Medicare Services to
raise the standards at our nursing homes
increase inspections at our nursing
homes and today we're offering very
specific guidance which Seema Verma will
articulate about visitations at nursing
homes it's important to remember that
they were there for us when we were
growing up mr. president they helped us
with our homework they tucked us in at
night they cheered us on as we pursued
education cheered us on in our careers
and now it's time for us to be there for
them and to recognize that seniors with
chronic health conditions are the most
vulnerable and Americans can make a
difference so wash your hands use common
sense look after the most vulnerable and
a mr. president I know I join you in
saying that every American should be
proud of this incredible public/private
partnership that's going to be speeding
access of testing to millions of
Americans in the weeks ahead and
together as you've said many times
together we'll get through this together
we'll put the health of America first
as Seba where Seba I'd like you to baby
take that a step further please Oh
nursing thank you well thank you to the
president for the declaration it allows
my agency CMS that runs Medicare and
Medicaid and has oversight of all of the
nation's health care facilities to
suspend regulations that could get in
the way of treating patients during this
time these temporary national blanket
waivers are reserved for the rarest of
circumstances and they represent a
massive mobilization of our country's
resources to combat this terrible virus
and the flexibilities we are offering
will be a godsend to the providers
clinicians and facilities on the
frontlines of this fight and later CMS
is going to be issuing guidance
directing nursing homes to temporarily
restrict all visitors and non-essential
personnel with a few exceptions such as
end of life situations we fully
appreciate that this measure represents
a severe trial for residents of nursing
homes and those who love them but we are
doing what we must to protect our
vulnerable elderly thank you as I said
in my address to the nation the other
night all Americans have a role to play
in defeating this virus our most
effective weapon right now is to limit
the damage to our people and our country
and slow the spread of the virus itself
the choice we make the precautions we
put into place are critical to
overcoming the virus reducing its spread
and shortening the duration of the
pandemic which is what it is the CDC has
published guidelines on the corona virus
dot-gov to enable its coronavirus
dot-gov
and it's very ly very heavily used right
now I will say to enable every American
to respond to this epidemic and to
protect themselves their families and
their communities while the risks the
young and healthy Americans remains very
low
we've learned a lot about this over the
last two weeks anyone can be a carrier
for the virus and risk transmission to
older Americans and those with
underlying health conditions and those
who are most at risk they have not done
very well
older Americans who were especially if
they have a health problem they have not
done well we must take all precautions
and be responsible for the actions that
we take and that we see other people
take we want to prevent the spread and
transmission of the disease it's
incredible what's sports what's
happening with the sporting world where
so many of the great sports that we've
gotten so used to at this time of the
year they're not going to be meaning and
they've done it a great service actually
but that would be another way that it
could be problems could be caused but
this is why I outlined on Wednesday
night my admission administration's the
fact that we've issued a requirement
suspending all medically unnecessary
visits to various places but in
particular nursing homes we should all
be working off the same playbook when it
comes to protecting Americans we have to
we need to be consistent and adopting
measures to limit the spread of the
virus the virus is the same whether it's
spreading in cities towns or rural
communities the tools and tactics for
attacking it are similar no matter where
you go you know I don't way you go you
have some hotspots throughout the world
right now that people would have never
thought possible and they're being very
seriously affected the key among these
efforts are breaking chains of
transmission between people these
measures have been adopted by many
companies universities and schools and
we want to protect the safety and the
health of their employees and their
students I encourage everyone to follow
the guidelines we've issued by CDC and
these common-sense measures a lot of
it's common sense for the areas where
the virus is spreading the CDC is
advising communities to pose
phone large gatherings postpone
assemblies social functions and sporting
events stagger recess and lunch for
schools that aren't canceled limit in
person meetings increased scheduled
cleanings then cancel work sponsored
travel among numerous other steps that
can be taken Americans are the strongest
and most resilient people on earth and
in the coming weeks we will all have to
make changes and sacrifices but these
short-term sacrifices will produce
long-term gain and again I've said we're
learning a lot for the future and future
problems like this or worse or worse it
could get worse the next eight weeks are
critical we can learn and we will turn a
corner on this virus some of the doctors
say it will wash through it will flow
through and interesting terms and very
accurate I think you're gonna find in a
number of weeks it's going to be a very
accurate term in times of hardship the
true character of America always shines
through we live in the company of the
greatest heroes and the most inspiring
citizens anywhere in the world we want
to take care of our people we want to
draw on the strength of our history draw
in the strength of our people and we
will get through this all together we
will just get through it
so much progress has already been made
and frankly the numbers because the
steps that have been taken or at a level
that a lot of people are surprised
especially when you compare them with
other places with far smaller
populations the spirit in the will of
our nation is unbreakable we will defeat
this threat when America is tested
America rises to the occasion and to
those families and citizens who are
worried and concerned for themselves and
their loved ones I want you to know that
your federal government will unleash
every authority resource and tool in its
disposal to safeguard the lives and
health of our people
so we're with you every step of the way
no nation
is more prepared or more equipped to
face down this crisis as you know we a
rated number one in the world we're also
helping other nations many other nations
were helping them a lot and in doing
okay in some cases in some cases they're
not doing well at all but we're working
with a lot of groups of people and a lot
of other nations with faith and heart
and hope and love and determination we
will succeed we will prevail we will be
very very successful and we'll learn for
the future thank you all very much if
you have any questions we can take so go
ahead please and if you'd like to ask
some of the folks up here would be fine
pleasure mr. president where are you
with the House bill yesterday we talked
to you in the Oval Office you were
opposed to it what has happened since
then and and what's the holdup on that
well we just don't think they're giving
enough we don't think the Democrats are
giving enough we're negotiating we
thought we had something but all of a
sudden and they didn't agree to certain
things that they agreed to so we could
have something but we don't think
they're giving enough they're not
they're not doing what's right for the
country and if I could ask doctor foul
sure go ahead please Thank You mr.
president you just mentioned waiving
interest for student loans you talked
about buying oil from the spar or adding
to the SPR what other specific targeted
measures is your administration thinking
about taking the Treasury secretary
Steve Manutius said today that you're
just in the second inning of yang's that
you want the underground that's true and
we are looking at many different things
as you know you know some of them
they've been written about very widely
but we're going to be releasing a paper
in about two hours
stating quite a few other steps very
important once please go ahead please
thank you so much mr. president I wonder
I want to know if you are in contact
with the Brazilian President Besson ro
after a member of his delegation who was
with you Saturday was tested positive
and also senator I want to ask another
question if you like me senators Lindsey
Graham and also Senator Scott Rick Scott
ourself isolating are you planning to
take any kind of precursor any
precautionary measure
to protect you and also your staff who
was there no we have no symptoms
whatsoever and we have we had a great
meeting with the president of Brazil
Paulson our oh great guy very a very
tremendous he's done he's doing a
fantastic job for Brazil and as you know
he tested negative meaning nothing wrong
this morning and we got that word too
because we did have dinner with him
we were sitting next to each other for a
long period of time but are you in
contact with him over the coronaviruses
we have we're talking about it country
to country but we did discuss if he had
a problem it was reported that he may
have it and he doesn't fortunately much
mr. president
doctor foul chief said earlier this week
that the lag in testing was in fact a
failing do you take responsibility for
that and when can you guarantee that
every single American who needs a test
will be able to have a test what's the
date of that yeah no I don't take
responsibility at all because we were
given a a set of circumstances and we
were given rules regulations and
specifications from a different time was
it meant for this kind of an event with
the kind of numbers that we're talking
about and what we've done is redesigned
it very quickly with the help of the
people behind me and we're now in very
very strong shape I think we'll be
announcing as I said Sunday night and
this will start very quickly and we have
will have the ability to do in the
millions over a very very quick period
of time so no and what we have done and
we are going to be leaving a very
indelible print for the future in case
something like this happens again but it
was a and that's not the fault of
anybody and frankly the old system
worked very well for smaller numbers
much smaller numbers but not for these
kind of numbers Tony maybe it will every
American be able to get a test so just
to reiterate what I said to many of you
multiple times it's a distant of a
system the system was not designed for
what it was designed for it worked very
well
the CDC designed
system if you want to get the kind of
blanket testing and availability that
anybody can get it or you could even do
surveillance to find out what the
penetrance is you have to embrace the
private sector and this is exactly what
you're seeing because you can't do it
without it so when I said that I meant
the system was not designed for what we
need now looking forward the system will
take care of it mr. president
and interestingly if you go back please
if you go back to the swine flu it was
nothing like this they didn't do testing
like this and actually they had lost
approximately 14,000 people and they
didn't do the testing they started I
thinking about testing when it was far
too late what we've done and one of the
reasons I think people are respecting
what we've done we've done it very early
we've gotten it very early and we've
also kept a lot of people out well ask
them how they did with the swine flu is
a disaster next place next place they
had a very big failure with swine flu a
very big failure president I want to ask
you about the European travel ban that
goes into effect at midnight tonight and
the exemption that you've offered to the
UK there are 17 countries that are in
the so-called Schengen zone that have
fewer coronavirus cases than the UK and
just in the past 24 hours the UK has
added 208 coronavirus cases to their
total why do they mr. president deserve
an exemption and would you consider
adding them to this travel ban list
well that was recommended to me by a
group of professionals and we are
looking at it based on the new numbers
that are coming out and we may have to
include them in the list of countries
that we will you could say ban or
whatever it is during this period of
time but yeah the numbers have gone up
fairly precipitously over the last 24
hours so we may be adding that and we
may be adding a couple of others and we
may frankly start thinking about taking
some off
Thank You mr. president
I'm not corresponding with hong kong
phoenix TV um you have been mentioned
you have mentioned that number in china
has been decreasing in China has made
tremendous progress in the past weeks
I'm wondering how much confidence does
this give you to control the virus in
the United States and do you see the
data China has been sharing with the
United States has been helpful I think
it has been helpful we've been working
very much with China
I've spoken as you know with President
Xi they went through hell and their
numbers are starting to look very good
they're really they're really looking
very good we're very happy about that
we are sharing data yes in fact we're
sharing quite a bit of data including
the fact that some of our pharmaceutical
companies are working over there right
down with large groups of people
yeah go ahead please Thank You mr.
president you spoke with Canadian Prime
Minister Trudeau yesterday did you
discuss the potential closing of the
border between the Canada and the US and
by extension
are you considering ways to salvage the
two billion dollar daily trade between
the two countries so we didn't discuss
the border we've had a very good
relationship just about finished with
the u.s. MCA as you know he called
actually called me to tell me that I
think that was the primary reason for
the call at the time his wife had not
been diagnosed and she's a lovely lady
wonderful lady great lady and since then
I've heard read that the result was that
she has it and there was a little
surprise I think he was surprised also
we did discuss it prior to she's going
to be fine but he thought that she would
not most likely have the virus
unfortunately she does but we didn't
discuss the border yesterday don't
go ahead please if you have any
questions for these great geniuses up
here you should even a business question
related to what we're talking about
mister president Russell Palumbo from
ABC News Miami is a relatively new
Floridian what is your message today to
the cruise line industry in the travel
industry that Florida depends upon and
since senator Rick Scott and miami-dade
Mayor Carlos Jimenez have the same
exposure as you and they ourself I like
isolating what's your message to them
that they shouldn't be well I don't know
that I had exposure but I don't have any
of the symptoms and we do have a white
house doctor and I should say many White
House doctors too frankly and I asked
them that same question and they said
you don't have any symptoms whatsoever
and we don't want people without
symptoms to go and do the tests the test
is not insignificant as far as the
cruise line business we're with them all
the way it's a great business it's a
great US business frankly and I know how
important they are to the country that
includes Airlines but the cruise line
business obviously was hit very hard we
had a tremendous success out in Oakland
where we moved at vice president pence
did a fantastic job with that we worked
with UK we worked with Canada and they
took their people back in Canada is
approximately 600 people UK likewise
took a large number of people back to
the United Kingdom and we have people
quarantined it was a big operation and
worked out really you don't hear about
it anymore it worked out really well you
Mike you may even want to say something
about that because that was really done
properly well thank you mr. president
and that that that program with the
grand princess the ship is continuing to
be administered in the highest standards
orderly way as the president directed
and Americans that needed treatment have
received them I spoke to the governor of
Iowa today and some of those who now
have been cleared are are able in proper
supervision to be returning to Iowa
they're making arrangements for them to
do that others in Texas others in
Georgia again it's another example
the extraordinary cooperation Governor
Abbott Governor Gavin Newsom
governor Bryant Kemp of Georgia but to
add to that the president directed me
last Saturday to travel down to Miami we
met with all the leaders of the cruise
line industry several cruise lines have
announced a 60-day pause in operations
our Department of Homeland Security has
praised them for doing that because of
the unique health challenges
particularly presented to seniors with
underlying conditions we have a proposal
from the cruise line industry but
they're currently considering what other
steps that they might take perhaps even
similar to what those other lines have
taken we're anticipating some response
on that in the next 24 hours but as the
president said the American people
cherish our cruise line industry men and
women who work on the ships and women
who work on the shore all the economies
that are so benefited by a vibrant
cruise line industry and what the
president's directed us to do is whether
there whether there is a pause in the
moment as some cruise lines are doing
and as we all continue to discuss we
want to work with the cruise line
industry to ensure that when we come
through this that cruise lines and the
medical services that are available and
for the passengers and and all of the
crew that that cruise lines are safer
than ever before and can prosper for
many years to come
go ahead please this question is for
doctors a foul she and Burke Burke's
doctor fowey based on what you currently
know what is the trajectory for when
this outbreak will peak how long will
the American people have to remain on
this emergency footing and for dr. Burks
as the administration tries to get its
arms around this testkit shortage issue
the next glaring need could be
respirators and related hospital
equipment so what does the
administration doing right now to ramp
up production of respirators and then
that kind of equipment should this
outbreak persistent so when you have an
outbreak like this particularly if
you're trying to interfere with it it's
really impossible to predict the time
element of when it's going to peak and
when it's naturally going to go down so
if you look at the situation where
countries really did not get to the
point of trying to contain and mitigate
very well you see a peak over several
weeks and then down again over other
several weeks what we're trying to do
with the efforts that we're doing is to
blunt that peak and I mentioned that
many times and I think it's important
and appropriate for me to mention it
again because it answers your question
when you talk about preventing
infections from without in which is the
kind of travel of restrictions we're
talking about then how do you handle
what you already have in your country
you continue some sort of containment
but you also do mitigation and you try
to proportionate to the areas where
there are the most infections the
success of that and how much you make
this turn into this is going to give you
the amount of time if we're successful
it'll be less if we're not successful
it's going to be more but these kind of
things generally run out in a few months
hopefully we'll make it several weeks
eight nine whatever weeks but I can't
give you a number because it depends on
how successful we are great thank you
it's a great question and dr. Falchi and
I've worked together a very long time
and continue it's a privilege to work
with him every day so I think you can
learn very and I appreciate there was
some graphics done by some of the
reporting over the last several days if
you Ally
the data from China with the data with
South Korea you can start to see as a
complete overlay of that data and so
that's what we're tracking very closely
as well as Italy but you have an
excellent question I just want to make
one note in South Korea I want to repeat
only 4% of the tests were positive that
means 96% of the people had a different
respiratory disease because we're in the
middle of flu season cold season and all
of the other respiratory diseases that
we get every day in LabCorp and quest
early data they're running about one to
two percent positive that means that we
have a lot more other respiratory
disease out there besides the corona
virus and that's why the screening is
critical but even with the screening
we're gonna reload run what we think are
very low rates
needless to say though we're taking
extraordinarily seriously to plan for
what could come not what what doctor
felt you talked about blunting the curve
that makes it much less high need at
that peak of the curve that we're all
planning for it so we're in full
inventory of all of our assets by the
president unlocking and this emergency
order and the Secretary of HHS is
ability it unlocks all of those
stockpiles those needs what the VA has
what the DoD has what the National Guard
has and what every hospital has and the
hospital emergency preparedness plan
allows them to defer elective issues to
keep those hospital beds open for those
who might need them so we're in full
planning mode for each of those things
and I might add that we are in the
process and in some cases have already
done it ordered a large number of
respirators just in case we hope we
don't need them but we've ordered a
large number yeah go ahead please thank
you very much mr. president
in your speech to the nation you
mentioned the situation in China and
South Korea have improved and you're
thinking about remove the restrictions
also the warning but in place right now
when can we expect that announcement and
how do you see the overall progress that
Asian countries make well some are
making progress some are not as you
but some are making progress and as they
make progress as they get down to the
number that we all think is right
that they know is right we know is right
we'll be opening it up and some are
really moving along rapidly we hope to
be able to open things up as quickly as
possible go ahead please go ahead I'd
like to ask secretary a czar and dr.
Foust
Fozzy just how dr. foul Qi okay better
not a hundred percent but 90 percent
this affects the elderly primarily and
in that sense it's an unusual disease is
any specific research being done as to
why it affects our senior citizens more
than others so I I don't mean to to
diminish your your question but we
already know why it would affect senior
citizens more because when you talk
about anything that requires a robust
immune system as you get older your
immune system is not as potent as it is
when you are young and that's the reason
why when you talk about even influenza
which we have extraordinary experience
with over decades and decades the people
who are very vulnerable are the elderly
and those with underlying conditions the
same thing holds true for a variety of
other disease why cancer is more
prevalent in some in mostly in older
individuals because the immune system
that screens for it is less robust so
what really is something that is kind of
well known over a lot of studies Oh a in
place oh yeah
mr. president the Chinese officials are
expressing some tones of discontent with
how we're the source of this virus has
come from and they're spinning some odd
narratives what are your response to the
Chinese officials who are doing that and
have they signaled any kind of
resistance
two upcoming trade talks in in response
to how we're handling the deal with
China they're gonna be buying two
hundred and fifty billion dollars worth
of goods and fifty billion from our
farmers and it's a great deal for our
country it's about time somebody did
that and frankly phase two will start
negotiating I did read one article but I
don't think that article was
representative certainly not in my
conversations with President Xi and they
know where it came from we all know
where it came from
thank you mr. president you Michel
thunder from PBS newshour
my first question is you said that you
don't take responsibility but you did
disband the white house pandemic office
and the officials that were working in
that office left this administration
abruptly so what responsibilities do you
take to that and the officials that
worked in that office said that you that
the white house lost valuable time
because that office wasn't disbanded
what do you make of that well I just
think it's a nasty question because what
we've done is and Tony had said numerous
times that we've saved thousands of
lives because of the quick closing and
when you say me I didn't do it we have a
group of people I could I could ask
perhaps by administration but I could
perhaps ask Tony about that because I
don't know anything about it I mean you
say you say we did that I don't know
anything about it in straigh ssin
perhaps they do that you know people let
people go you used to be with a
different newspaper than you are now you
know things like that happen we're doing
a great job let me tell you these
professionals behind me and the these
great incredible doctors and
businesspeople the best in the world and
I can say that whether it's retailers or
or labs or anything you want to say
these are the best of the world we're
doing a great job and we have 40 people
right now 40 compare that with other
countries that have many many times that
amount now one of the reasons we have 40
and others have and again that numbers
going up just so you understand and a
number of cases which are very small
relatively speaking it's going up but
we've done a great job because we acted
quickly we acted
and there's nothing we could have done
that was better than closing our borders
to highly infected areas please go ahead
Thank You mr. president banessa at least
for ntn24 for a latin-american country
and also for Spain Laura Thoren Anton
address I would like to ask you two very
brief questions 1m for how long we're
gonna have the emergency them I mean the
national emergency and I hope not long
but it's there now and it gives
tremendous powers for things that we
need tremendous power actually and the
Stafford Act and various other things
that were involved with and have studied
and memorized in so many different ways
and forms it gives the kind of power
that we need to get rid of this virus
and we're gonna do it very quickly and I
hope we won't need it very long but
whatever it takes so for now we still
don't know for how long and I have
something very important I wanted to ask
you is like how do you think do you
really think it's essential coordinating
with other countries and learning from
the lessons that they already suffer
these same situation countries of course
like China and South Korea but now
recently Italy and Spain that
coordination done very we're in touch
with Italy and you know it's a it's a
country that we love we have tremendous
millions and millions of people
originally origins from Italy and we're
working with them there in a very there
and probably relatively speaking the
toughest position of all we're in touch
with everybody we're in touch with when
I say everybody we're in touch with many
of the countries that you know about
that you're writing about and they're
calling us asking for advice they're
asking for the advice of the people
behind me
Italy's got a tough situation but
they're they're really they have really
clamped down and I think they're gonna
see some very good results it's tough
what they did they really took their
medicine but they're going to see some
much better results yeah Jeff
thank you sir with regard to domestic
travel should Americans feel safe or
should Americans at all be traveling to
states such as Washington State New York
and other hotspots within
country and a follow up on Brazil you're
asking people who come back from America
from Europe Americans were coming back
from Europe to self quarantine for a
couple weeks you were in a picture with
somebody who now has coronavirus from
Brazil at mar-a-lago how is that
different well I'll tell you first of
all I'm not coming back from someplace
exposed we there was somebody that they
say has it I have no idea who he is but
I take pictures and it lasts for
literally seconds I don't know the
gentleman that we're talking about have
no idea who he is I haven't seen the
picture I said there's a picture of
somebody but I take sometimes hundreds
of pictures a day and that night I was
taking hundreds of pictures so I just
don't know now I did sit with the
president for probably two hours but
he's tested negative so that's good it's
just a matter of his good and go ahead
please I would say if you stay home it's
not bad it's not bad now there are
certain parts of the country that are
essentially have known zero problem
Washington's been very tough in
particular nursing home and Washington
the state of Washington has been very
tough it's been a big percentage of when
you talk about the forty deaths that's
been a big percentage of the deaths as
you know very well and they all came
from a very a certain area unfortunately
please go ahead go ahead okay thank you
very much mr. president
cordelia Lynch Sky News you talk this
week about the UK doing a good job in
tackling coronavirus in light of the
rise in cases are you changing your mind
about that you also just spoke about
possible travel restrictions have you
discussed when they might be put in
place well in light of the results as we
discussed before a lot of the results
we're going to be looking at it and I
know the the task force is looking at it
very strongly vice president everybody
it was looking good but they've the
results have been building up pretty
rapidly so will will be taking another
look at that yes absolutely
go ahead please mr. president thank you
I want to first follow up on Jeff's
question because the person you were
standing next to whether you know who he
is or not tested positive for
coronavirus dr. Falchi said this morning
if you stand next to somebody who tested
positive
you should self isolate and get a test
you say your White House doctor is
telling you something different
who should Americans listen to and my
second I think they have to listen to
their doctors and I think they shouldn't
be jumping to get the tests unless it's
necessary but I think they have to
listen to their doctors and I mean I
don't know that I haven't seen the
picture somebody said there's a picture
with somebody taking a picture with me
but I haven't seen it symptoms are you
being selfish by not getting tested and
potentially why did say I wasn't going
to be tested are you going to be most
likely yeah mostly not for that reason
but because I think I will do it anyway
well fairly soon we're working on that
we're working out of schedule my second
question is you go ahead please go ahead
yeah I know there's been a lot of talk
about testing I just want to make sure
we're clear though because we've been
hearing from doctors who say as of today
they still can't get patients tested who
need a test so as of today can everyone
who a doctor once have tested get tested
and if not win well it's been true for a
while but I'll let Mike what on the ends
of that bike well as the president said
and dr. pouchy has articulated the
nature of our current system where the
CDC has samples sent and tests are
perform or State labs perform tests or
in some cases University and hospital
labs perform tests it's generally
adequate for an infectious disease or
for people getting a diagnostic work
done but given the sheer scale of this
the president tasked us with bringing
together this extraordinary public and
private partnership today by some
estimates when you add all the labs
together and today
the president made it possible for every
state in the country and their state
labs to authorize labs across their
state to do coronavirus testing we're
estimating somewhere between 15 and 20
thousand tests a day are able to be
performed but very soon with with the
program that was announced today
Americans will be able to visit one of
the sites closest to them as described
on the website if they're symptomatic if
the questionnaire indicates it be able
to have a test there and these
incredible companies will will process
the test and and they'll receive that
information but for now the best advice
that we can give for people is to speak
to their doctor as the president just
said and if the doctor indicates that
physician if it's not a university
hospital
or otherwise authorized lab can contact
the state lab and again every state lab
in the country can perform tests today
but what the president charged us with
when I was tasked to take over the White
House coronavirus task force was open up
tests all across the country the
president said a few days ago that we
made it clear that any American that
wanted to get a test would be able
clinically to get a test because I
literally heard from the governor of
Washington State who said the doctors in
Washington state were saying that if you
were only mildly symptomatic they would
not order a test and fortunately the
president directed CDC to clarify that
now anyone in consultation with their
physician regardless of their symptoms
can request a test and their doctors
will contact those those agencies those
labs in their state but very soon
Americans will be able to go to these
these drive-in sites and be able to
obtain and participate in a test dr.
Burks is it more to amplify that I think
that's that's perfectly said I think
just to review what's 4-time about the
testing with LabCorp and quest i think
many of you have been to doctors office
and seen the little boxes outside what
they do is they deliver bow
the specimen collection piece because
remember it's a nasal swab it's not a
tube of blood so they've delivered that
to doctors offices and hospitals and
then they will arrange to pick that up
the important piece in this all is
they've gone from a machine that may
have a lower throughput to the 'but at
potential to have automated extraction i
know you don't want all these details
but it's really key for the laboratory
people it's an automated extraction of
the RNA that then runs in an automated
way on the machine with no one touching
it and the result comes out of the other
end so sample 2 machine 2 results that
cuts out a lot of the manual pieces that
were happening that we're delaying the
test results and so with that what's the
timeline like from when you're tested to
when you get results like next week what
should people expect well with the prior
testing it was taking several days
because the test is slower we believe
with this test because of its throughput
that the testing can be from start
remember it has to transport to the
laboratory that will run it and then
we're hoping that all can be finished
within 24 hours which is very similar to
other tests that you receive today these
are not point-of-care tests we are
working on point-of-care tests but we
have to realize point-of-care tests take
six months or more to develop so we're
not waiting for those we're still
diagnosing this on nucleic acid so as an
antibody this is actually the antigen
the actual virus in your nose that were
amplifying I think you have to remember
though we're working very closely with
States and this you have a smaller form
and more targeted form of government
going in and doing it like in New York
where the relationship is very good like
gavin newsom where he made some very
complimentary care that's California he
made some really complimentary comments
the other day about how we're working
together we worked on the ship together
but we worked on a lot of other things
together having to do with this and
we'll really the relationship that we
have I can't think of a bad relationship
we're helping them
we're funding them in some cases
depending on what it is you're talking
about and we're all working together
very closely so we've done really I
think a tremendous job of of teamwork
with the different states right one or
two more and if you have if you have
questions for these folks does anybody
have a question for the folks up here
who has a question up here you have okay
go ahead if you have a question go ahead
thank you I have one for you as well
because I them first yes I will okay
with regards to the CEOs can you please
tell us when you expect to see items
like hand sanitizer that have been going
out of stock very quickly back on the
shelves there have been a lot of reports
about that and for You mr. president
could you talk about a potential bailout
for the cruise industry you would
suggested that could happen is that
something you're still looking at and
how much would that be well I didn't
suggest that it could happen but I can
tell you it's an industry that was very
badly impacted by what's going on with
the virus and it's a great industry it's
a very important industry and we will be
helping them and we will be helping the
airline industry if we have to assuming
we have to so far people have been
asking but if they should be asking will
we want to make sure our airline is very
strong and then one day and one day all
of a sudden wasn't looking so good
interestingly we're just talking or sake
to Doug and the numbers they're doing
from the retailing standpoint I guess
because of this your business is like
the opposite all of you have been you've
been selling a lot of a lot of stuff you
want to answer the question as to the
hand sanitizers specifically the areas
where we're seeing pressure in the
supply chain or surface cleaners
cleaning supplies paper goods in
particular and hand sanitizer is going
to be very difficult to have a hundred
percent in stock on for some time we're
still replenishing it and shipping it
but as soon as it's the stores it's
going the same things true for the
categories I just mentioned so all the
retailers will be working hand-in-hand
with the suppliers to bring that to the
market as fast as we can what is your
advice though for Americans who were
seeking those items what is your advice
for selling out online their selling out
in the stores I think I think this team
has given you other example
of what people can do to fight back
against this virus and you should look
at the entire list I mean obviously it
sounds very simplistic but wash your
hands as often as you possibly can and I
know you're not always in a position to
be able to wash your hands
but wash them is as much as you can if
you don't have the the alcohol wipes try
and get them if you can't get them just
try as best as possible to do it I mean
you got to do the best you can well just
general preparedness you know you want
to wash your hands you want to keep
distance from people and if you're
around someone sick just keep away from
them this is basic basic public health
no these guys are selling a lot of
toilet paper I don't know there seems to
Tony to give some guidance that that
that toilet paper is not an effective
protection against getting the corona
virus they're worth selling out but the
soap and water hot water soap 20 seconds
that's how you do it thank you very much
mr. president you have a great team of
course that's true my question is mr.
president are you happy from the Chinese
response what correctly really told you
what really happened those days and
second Prime Minister Modi or India have
closed borders until April 15th if you
have spoken with the Prime Minister of
India and if they have needed any help
and finally sir any message for the
small businesses because they are losing
some businesses because of this thank
you sir well on small businesses the
Small Business Administration is now
stacked with money to help them and
we're going to make the money readily
available if they needed small
businesses we had a great time in India
there was an incredible two days and
he's a great friend of mine and he's a
friend of his people because he was
greeted incredibly warmly as was I in
that Stadium it was an incredible event
and I loved being with him so just say
hello to him but we we talked about
everything we talked about far more than
just borders and as far as president she
likewise he's a friend of mine
I believe that we are dealing in good
faith that we just worked as you know
and as I just said he we just worked at
an incredible deal big deal one of the
biggest deals ever made of any kind
big even by the standards of some of the
people here the deal with China but I
think that they want to get to the
bottom of things also we're working our
drug companies our pharmaceutical
companies are working very closely with
China and with India as you know and
with all over the world
and they're all over the world these are
magnificent companies that are very very
knowledgeable and it's we're very lucky
to have them because I think you're
going to come up with whether it's
therapeutic or whether it's just help
helping getting better and then
ultimately a vaccine which takes a
little bit longer because of the test
periods and a couple of other reasons
you're gonna have it very quickly
because of the the great knowledge and
they'll have it very quickly they've
made a tremendous amount of progress
thank you all very much we appreciate it
thank you thank you very much
[Music]